in case you haven't heard there is a
major threat to our democracy it turns
out that according to reputable polling
the majority of americans intend to vote
for republicans in the coming elections
and and this constitutes
a major threat to our democracy it it
very well might destroy our democracy
according to the former republican
turned liberal columnist
max booth mr boot announced that a
recent gallup poll indicating a major
shift among the voting public from
democrat to republican constitutes quote
an ominous sign for the future of u.s
democracy
gallup found that this swing from
democrat to republican is quote the
biggest swing in gallup's 30 years of
tracking
so you see the people
don't like our current rulers and they
want to go to the ballot box and vote
them out
and this is a major threat to our
democracy according to the liberals and
the court jesters of the ruling class on
the right they keep using that word
democracy i do not think it means what
they think it means i'm michael knowles
this is the micro noise show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from
oe
oefonlyx33 who says
so what are you in for
i called a man a man when i was prepping
him for his prostate exam dang that's
rough
what about you
i shot my boyfriend and stole his drugs
this is true that is a real conversation
i imagine that's going on in canada
jails might be happening in california
jails pretty soon that's unfortunate
that's a real downside for our culture
now when you want an upside i would
strongly recommend you check out
get upside are you spending too much
money on gas right now i know you if you
live in america you are spending too
much money on gas well i've got a little
relief for you
that would be get upside yet upside it's
a free app you go in you download the
free app and then you get
25 cents per gallon cash back
every time you fill up your tank well
that's not quite true the first time you
fill up your tank you will actually get
50 cents per gallon cash back
if you use the code knowles k w l e s
there's no cash there's only cash back
it goes right into your bank account you
don't need to worry about it or if you
prefer you can get
the money via paypal you can get it
through an e-gift card for amazon and
other companies or you get it right into
the bank account everyone could use a
little relief at the pump these days you
can get it if you go to get upside you
download that app you use code knowles
you will get up to 50 cents per gallon
cash back on your first fill up that is
code knowles k-n-o-w-l-e-s
just a little gift from me to you enjoy
uh
amid all the craziness in our society
right now a lovely little upside
democracy is whenever we do the things
the liberals want and whenever the
people don't want the things the
liberals want that is not democracy
that's a threat to our democracy adrian
vermeule the harvard law professor and
conservative intellectual he has pointed
out that if you just replace the word
democracy with liberalism
when the left says there's a threat to
our democracy we have a sacred temple of
democracy then there are
currently incoherent babblings start to
make a little bit more sense and that's
what they're talking about you see this
in poland you see this in hungary you
see this throughout the west whenever
the people don't want liberalism this is
called a threat to our democracy it's
also a reminder that never trump was
never just about trump max boot made a
name for himself during the never trump
movement there were a handful of former
republicans who did the same
but it's not as though once donald trump
went away they all of a sudden started
supporting republicans again they still
support liberals they still support
democrats they want to vote the
republicans out of congress they want to
vote republicans out at the state level
too they want to discredit all
republicans there was that great meme
during the 2020 election which which
donald trump actually posted he tweeted
it out which was him sitting there and
he said
they're not after me they're after you
and i just happen to be in the way
according to the left
every american to the right of hillary
clinton is a horrible vicious vile
racist bigot terrible person hakeem
jeffries who's a democrat congressman
just made this claim almost verbatim
speaking from the house of
representatives
what happened to the modern day
republican party was it the election
that took place in 2008
that disturb you
did that throw you off
were you confused by that
still trying to figure out how it
occurred what happened
to the modern day republican
party that you've abandoned your own
principles
principles that richard nixon gerald
ford ronald reagan and george w bush
espoused and that 16 of you
voted to authorize
in 2006 what happened
to the modern day republican party it's
a cult right now
is it because the cult leader has told
you to oppose
voting rights
what happened republicans was it
something that happened in 2008
you racists
was it 2008 was so long ago
do you realize how long ago that what
they're still on about this
14 years ago
america elected a black eye president
the republicans didn't like him
not because he was black because he was
a terrible president one of the worst
presidents ever although joe biden has
given him a run for his money and i
think probably superseded him
we couldn't oppose barack obama and
certainly the modern democrat party
because
they are
knocking down our statues attacking our
country disrespecting our flag
indoctrinating our kids in radical
leftism in radical racial theories
in insane gender and sexual theories it
couldn't be that it's because we don't
like black people right
except
the the current democrat president is
white there are plenty of prominent
black republicans so they got to go back
to 2008 and say you you don't like him
because he's black a reminder about this
joker hakeem jeffries his uncle is a man
named leonard jeffries
leonard jeffries made a name for himself
because he was an infamous professor
who had a theory that white people are
the ice people
they're they're callous they're cruel
they're oppressors they're the ice
people and black people are the people
of the sun they're warm they're nice
they're loving and he he taught this for
years and years at cuny
finally they ran him out of there but
apparently bile runs in the family
hakeem jeffries i suspect
is simply upset that the democrats are
doing terribly in the polls and they
don't look like they're going to do very
well in the midterm elections and so
he's saying what happened to the
republican party
what he means is
why aren't you guys docile losers
anymore
why aren't you guys losers why aren't
you guys just going along with whatever
we want
we can't get anything passed here in
congress we can't we can't pass a
federal election takeover we can't
pass a repeal of the filibuster in the
senate we gosh we can't even pass a
budget
why won't you guys let us do that
you must be racists
now there has been polling on this
there's pulling out of pew research
which showed that white people
are the least racist racial group
because they have the lowest racial
consciousness for every other racial
group the sense of racial consciousness
their race being somewhat or very
important to their sense of identity is
higher than 50 percent that's true of
asians that's true of hispanics and it's
especially true of blacks who have uh
racial consciousness north of 70
the number for white people is 15
not 50 15
it was a very low
low racial consciousness
and the gop there are plenty of hispanic
republicans that's worrying the
democrats right now and there are a
number of black republicans as well
and in terms of the party elected
officials and appointed officials there
are many black republicans
the gop may be the least racist party in
the history of political parties it was
founded to abolish slavery specifically
founded for that goal and the democrats
now claim that the parties switched one
day in the 1960s the democrats and the
republicans they all sat down they said
okay from now on you're going to be the
republicans and we're going to be the
democrats okay why are we doing that i
have absolutely no idea but that's what
we're going to do it's not not plausible
but you look at the current
republican party anytime there is a
black republican who's talented at
politics who has the right ideas the gop
promotes that politician as best they
can
in in no small part to counter this
preposterous narrative that you're
hearing from schmucks like hakim
jeffries and the rest of the democrats
you republicans it's because of your
white supremacist privilege privilege
that's what we're always hearing about
in the fairfax public schools right now
students are being taught lesson plans
about privilege i am very lucky that my
wonderful little son
is not in school yet we've got to figure
out what are we going to do i guess if
we can find a semi-sane private school
that's not
too expensive we're going to try to send
them there maybe we'll homeschool the
one thing we can't do is send
our kid to public schools if they are
teaching this racial and sexual crap a
fairfax county public school
has has a lesson right now about
privilege it's called privilege bingo
where students are given privileged
points if they are white
male
employed or involved in extracurricular
activities or feel
represented in the media
one of the privilege points goes to
military kids
so if you're
if your dad is in the army
you you are said to be privileged your
if your dad goes and deploys to some god
forsaken war-torn backwater and very
possibly could be killed by terrorists
fighting for our freedom
you are
privileged
that if you you could you have to
sacrifice seeing your father or your
mother for long periods of time and
possibly you could become an orphan that
makes you
privileged
of course this privileged bingo is the
opposite of reality do you know how i
know that white people and men are not
privileged by our society they have to
play the stupid privilege bingo and they
get called out and humiliated in front
of their classmates and you could never
do this for any other sexual or racial
group and you certainly certainly
shouldn't do this for a child whose
parents are serving the country and and
because of their service the child could
wind up an orphan that's the clearest
example of how extreme this has gotten
but it's true on every other alleged
privileged group
as well
it's just it's simple folks it's simple
and it's clean and when you want to
clean things very simply i would
recommend you check out naturally it's
clean i love naturally it's clean
i love it because the company is a good
company that shares our values that
defends the american way of life that
focuses on personal responsibility
environmental responsibility they're
really good guys
but frankly i would use naturally it's
clean even if it were produced in oh i
don't know
russia
or china or if it were made by the
taliban or if i i would
i would use the company even if it were
radical leftists running it because it's
that good they use plant-based enzymes
so that when you're cleaning you're not
just pushing the muck around you're
actually breaking down all that muck and
and
and gross stuff sitting around your
carpets and around your floors and
around your your table tops i gave it
the sweet little alisa test okay sweet
little alisa is a real stickler about
her cleaning products she is she was
very skeptical i bring it back she looks
she looks at the ingredients she looks
at
at how it's going to work and
she loves it she loves it i love it too
i would recommend starting with the
daily wire four pack of essentials which
include four great products you go to
naturally it's clean dot com slash
michael mich ael use promo code michael
to get 15 off your order cleaning
products are expensive if you keep a
clean home you will go through them fast
we encourage our listeners to not only
keep a clean home
but to support these wonderful companies
like naturally it's clean while you do
it
because they support your
conservative values head on over
naturallyitsclean.com
michael you will be blown away
speaking of what's going on abroad great
news out of the united kingdom
boris johnson prime minister over there
in the uk has just announced that there
will no longer be mandatory face masks
and covid passports at large events in
the united kingdom
this is really good news because the uk
and johnson in particular have gone back
and forth and back and forth at the
early part of kovid bojo
was going out shaking hands kissing
people he was ignoring all of the stupid
rules then he got kovid and he got
spooked about it
and he went completely in the other
direction and locked down and he's kept
this whole thing going well now he's
gone back into the direction of reason
and he's saying look
we can't live like this forever
we can't live
suspending the normal rules of society
forever and ever and ever especially now
where the dominant strain of covid is
omicron it's not particularly dangerous
compared to other
viruses it doesn't seem like there's
very much we can do to stop it from
spreading it's just going everywhere
it's extremely transmissible and the
vaccines don't appear to do a very good
job preventing infections
so we're just going to open up
the government is no longer advising
people to work from home
the compulsory face masks are going to
be scrapped in the classroom starting
thursday
covet 19 passes will not be needed to
gain entry to large events quote we will
trust the judgment of the british people
and no longer criminalize anyone who
chooses not to wear one
better late than never better late
than never
and
what do i care what's going on in the
united kingdom not very much in terms of
their country they can run their own
country but i am glad that they're
loosening up on this because
international pressure is going to help
to change our domestic policies okay if
if we're living in a world where every
single country is locked down and no one
can travel and everyone's wearing ten
masks that's going to affect how we
govern ourselves here in america as well
i very often talk on this show about how
the libertarian idea that we're all just
atomized individuals and what you do
doesn't affect me is not true because we
all live in a society and politics is
what we all do together well that's
certainly true at the domestic level
it's true at the international level too
especially as we are increasingly
governed by international bodies like
the world health organization like the
united nations and so on and so forth so
if bojo is going to say okay the uk is
done with this
that might help push us in the right
direction rather than
if if the world were just full of
australia's which are turning their
countries into prison camps because of
the cough
every republican in office right now
needs to use whatever political power
they have
to pressure our government to do the
same
to get rid of the masks to get rid of
the mandatory vaccines fortunately we
got this great ruling from the supreme
court where
the employers are no longer required by
the government
to enforce these mass mandates that's
good now we all need to push back
not just us in the culture but the
elected republican
politicians if you are an elected
republican and you are not using your
platform and your power right now to to
stop this you are dead to me okay i'm
i'm done with it
i i'm i'm just complete i understand
that members of congress can't do very
much i understand that members of the
united states senate even can't do very
much governors actually can do quite a
lot mayors can do quite a lot
we need a concerted effort we need
collective action here because
individuals
just choosing whether or not to wear the
masks
that's not going to cut it
we all need to come together
the uk is doing it some other countries
are doing it the united states needs to
do it as well now speaking of public
health
a protestant pastor got in a whole lot
of trouble a few days ago his name is
mike todd
i don't know anything about mike todd i
don't know anything really about his
theology or his liturgy he got in
trouble because he spit on his hand and
rubbed it on
a member of his congregation's face
he trended we were told he's an idiot
this is crazy this is spooky he should
be locked away here is what
mike todd said and did
he's changing something and you don't
see it clearly yet
but you hit
[Applause]
and this is where
most people
would not face jesus anymore
[Applause]
what most people would do
is turn
away
[Music]
[Applause]
the vision i'm about to give you
it might get nasty
all right the cough was probably
unnecessary i will admit that was a
little bit gross but the idea of a
pastor rubbing saliva on a on a member
of the congregation's face
is actually not that weird when you look
at the christian tradition actually in
the traditional rite of baptism
that has existed in the catholic church
for many many centuries the priest
has a little salive on his thumb and
rubs it on the nostrils and the ears of
the baby being baptized christ uses
saliva to spit in the dirt and rub it on
a man's face
in the gospels it's not that weird if
you are familiar with christianity
this guy mike todd i suspect i wouldn't
agree very much with his take on
theology and liturgy
but i don't really get what the big deal
is i guess the big deal is that we are
now living in a different religion we're
living under the cult of public health
where we're not even forget about
coughing in public forget about touching
someone especially with saliva we're not
even allowed to breathe
in the same room
we have to put masks on
we we can't we have to look at one
another as walking bags of
germs that are ready to kill us rather
than as our brothers in christ as our
fellow human beings
so i suspect the reason people reacted
so strongly against this
obviously he was trying to provoke a
reaction to begin with but the reason
people had such a reaction to this is
because we're living under the sway of a
different religion which
makes an idol out of your physical
health
even to the point of not not being
allowed to get sick anymore
you remember when people used to just
get sick sometimes and it was fine
remember when people used to have a cold
or the flu and it was just
fine like it wasn't pleasant but it was
okay that those days seem gone i my wife
and i joke now whenever we're on an
airplane or in a restaurant and i cough
just a little cough i'm not saying it's
a cove in cough i just go off she looks
at me she says you can't do that you're
going to get arrested
we're not allowed to do that anytime
someone
coughs or sneezes or has the sniffles
down
we say no that's
you've got to go away you've got to lock
yourself in your room
until you're 100
better
it's it's a cult and the
ruling class is enforcing the
orthodoxies of this cult don lemon
on cnn
is furious at the anti-vaxxers
who won't go along with dr fauci he says
they're stupid and they should not
participate in society
we need to stop listening to the people
and they they should not be part of
um polite society so to speak i can't do
my own research better than experts
who's who have devoted their lives to
medical and and scientific research when
i tell people i said you know they'll
say well i've been doing my own research
in uh last week i was in miami i said
how did you get to miami i flew that's
science
so if you don't believe in science why
didn't you walk
right if you it did it it's well because
i can always follow the science that's
the reason that you're here that's the
reason that you don't have polio that's
where we don't see polio cases that's
the reason why we don't see smallpox
cases is because your parents had the
wherewithal and the sense to get you
vaccinated as a child so i don't told
that they had to that you had to because
what we have to start doing things for
the greater good of society and not for
idiots who think that they can do their
own research or that they are above the
law
don lemon is saying i don't know
anything i don't do my own research i'm
completely ignorant i blindly follow the
experts
and if you don't do that you're stupid
if you do your own research and come to
your own opinions you're a dumb idiot
you dummy
you shouldn't be allowed to participate
in polite society
if if you had your way we'd still have
polio running rampant and smallpox and
all other sorts of diseases
by the way one i think one of the major
drivers for why those diseases no longer
exist is just basic
improvement to sanitation i'm not saying
the vaccines didn't play a role but but
also
the reason that public health has
improved actually until until very
recently where you see certain public
health measures have actually gone down
considerably including life expectancy
but before then the reason that public
health measures generally have improved
has not just been because of vaccines
though sure that's played a role but
it's because people are less cramped now
they have more
disinfectants they have more sanitation
they that's a big drive they have better
nutrition they all of these things play
a role
but
if you say that if you have any kind of
balanced view of what's going on in the
public health you're called an idiot
you're called an anti-vaxxer
by the zealots of this of this religion
if you say i've done my own research and
i have some questions about dr fauci who
lied to us about the masks who lied to
us about the efficacy of certain
vaccines who lied to us about the origin
of the coronavirus who lied light light
light got everything wrong and often was
intentionally deceitful about it if you
say hey the guy with this terrible
record of predictions maybe he's not
right about the thing he's predicting
right now
you are called an idiot it reminds me of
a line from euripides talk sense
to a fool
and he will call you foolish
euripides wrote that in an old book
called the bakke
if you want to read old books with our
friend ben shapiro you can tune to the
third thursday book club that's right i
have a book club over prageru this is a
fun book club where i talk to other
people we bring we we all discuss it we
sit down we we fly all over the country
to sit down with these experts with ben
he's just talking he look he's read a
lot of books he's going to give you his
take he's probably going to give it to a
mile a minute and you can tune into that
on the third thursday book club go to
third
thursdaybookclub.com on the third
thursday of each month ben will join
daily wire all access members for an
in-depth lecture and discussion of each
book right now you get 25 off of all
daily wire memberships with code 1984
over at dailywire.com subscribe can you
guess what the first book is going to be
join ben tonight 8 pm eastern 7 p.m
central at
dailywire.com we'll be right back with a
lot more
great news from corporate america when
was the last time any of us said that i
don't know i can't remember
starbucks announced in a memo this week
that it is not going to be enforcing a
vaccine mandate on its employees
this after the supreme court ruled in
favor of us and a lot of other american
workers but the daily wire brought the
suit saying that the osha mandate
requiring employers with 100 or more
employees to force you all to take the
fouchy algae are just not
acceptable not legal not constitutional
they're throwing them out and so what
starbucks
chief operating officer john culver said
his quote
we respect the court's ruling and will
comply
very interesting take from starbucks
because the court never said
that you can't mandate the vaccine on
your employees
the court never said that that's not
what the ruling meant
the court said that the mandate from the
government is illegal and well what it
actually said is it's going to remand it
the issue to the lower courts but
they're very likely to succeed on the
merits because
very likely the the mandate is illegal
and unconstitutional
but the court never said that if a
business wants to institute this mandate
that it's not allowed to do that
starbucks went further much further than
the court and said look
the court says
that the mandate is not
legal from the government that we don't
have to follow it so we're not going to
follow it
general electric did the same thing
general electric last week announced
that it was also suspending the
coronavirus vaccine requirement
following the court's ruling
the reason i mentioned this at all one
is good on starbucks the libs were
trying to make boycott starbucks trend
none of them are gonna boycott starbucks
they're all gonna get their
maple pumpkin triple frappuccino with
the peppermint ribbons they're never
gonna stop they're addicted they've been
addicted since they were 12. everyone's
going to keep going to starbucks so good
on them good on the company for doing
that
good on general electric for doing that
but the reason i bring up this story has
nothing to do with those individual
companies the reason i bring it up is
because this is a great example
of culture being downstream of politics
you know for at least a decade now
conservatives have become fond of saying
that politics is downstream of culture
so what you do in the government what
you do when you pass laws none of that
matters
what really matters is the movies that
we make what really matters is the music
that we listen to we've got to just in
the private sphere change the culture
and then the politics will follow sure
the culture has a great effect on our
government and the policies that we live
under
but the opposite is true
as well
the opposite is true as well when the
supreme court issues a ruling that will
change the culture
certainly happened in a number of cases
throughout the court's history and
you're seeing it happen here now the
legal precedent that the supreme court
is establishing
is being taken much further than the
court would would have it
by these companies
this is great news and a reminder to
conservatives that we need to wield the
political power in a just way in a right
way that the people give us on the happy
occasions that they give it to us now
speaking of liberal institutions
i
i made a mistake
okay i did something that i never should
have done i never would have expected
to have done i i don't know what i was
thinking
i trusted npr
well i don't know i don't know why i
trusted npr i didn't but
i reported yesterday
on a story that npr reported on the
story was that the chief justice of the
supreme court asked the other justices
to wear masks
gorsuch would not go along with this
and sonia sotomayor
was boycotting the court's
joint
sessions where all the justices are
getting together and speaking with one
another she was boycotting them and she
was piping in on skype
this is apparently completely fake
according to the supreme court that
never happened
chief justice roberts did not ask them
all to wear the masks and sonia
sotomayor did not boycott because of
neil gorsuch according to a joint
statement that the two judges gorsuch
and sonia sotomayor issued quote
reporting that justice sotomayor asked
justice gorsuch to wear a mask surprised
us
it is false
while we may sometimes disagree about
the law we are warm colleagues and
friends
i remember i had the privilege of
meeting scalia when i was a student
and we asked him about some of the
rumors we heard about the court and he
said don't believe any reporting on the
internal workings of the court no one is
allowed to report on that so if you're
hearing anything it's from someone who
is breaking the promise that they made a
clerk or a staff member breaking the
promise that they made not to go to the
press and so they're not trustworthy
people and so you can't believe it
either way
this could be some pr damage control
this could be the chief justice sitting
down the two justices and saying look we
need a united front issue this joint
statement
but
then you have to ask yourself okay who
do i trust more the supreme court of the
united states both the conservatives and
the liberals on it agreeing on this
thing
or npr
or the establishment media
not saying i trust either of them in
particular but if i had to choose i
would probably choose the supreme court
over npr
which is another reminder
that our corporate press
is no different
than soviet pravda
it's just propaganda for the ruling
class
they just run lies
and they run lies that are conducive to
the functioning of the liberal
establishment that runs our country
so why are they doing it
why did this story come out
assuming that the court is right and the
npr reporting was wrong why are they
doing this now i suspect
that the establishment media
and the liberal ruling class generally
have a political goal in mind i think
they are trying to sow division on the
court more than already exists
because there is a very
serious case coming down the pike
this case is the dobbs case this is why
i'm in washington dc right now you may
have noticed that my set has changed i'm
not in nashville i'm here in dc for the
march for life
for the pro-life summit
for all of this
pro-life advocacy
that has never been more important
because this year there is a case
that is being hurt that has already been
heard actually by the supreme court and
that they're going to decide on
to determine whether or not to overturn
roe versus wade
the ruling class does not like that very
much
and so i suspect they're trying to sow
division on the court
the the takeaway here
actually has nothing to do with life or
any particular court decision
it's that the corporate press
act in unison
you'll notice they'll change their
talking points
we heard for so long the vaccines are
super duper effective
they do stop infection they do stop
transmission
we've got to lock down we've got to wear
10 masks we can't go back to work and
then all of a sudden about two weeks ago
it all shifted well omicron might be
here forever well we might not be able
to avoid it well we can't stay locked
down indefinitely well maybe we should
only quarantine five days and it all
turned on a dime that's the way they
they function because they're not
speaking truth to power they are a bull
horn for the powerful
speaking of this issue of life
terrible story coming out of california
a ucla grad student was stabbed to death
at a furniture store
by a relatively young man shawn loval
smith
he stabbed brianna kupfer
who is only 24 years old stabbed her to
death last thursday afternoon as she
worked at the croft house store
on la brea avenue in los angeles very
familiar with la brea avenue
it's a nice furniture store
she's a ucla grad student in design
she's been
identified as the victim of this career
criminal with a rap sheet that includes
charges of assault with a deadly weapon
carrying a concealed weapon assault on a
police officer possession of a stolen
vehicle and other charges as well this
guy's got a rap sheet a mile long
if politicians had done their job and
locked this criminal up this young girl
would be alive
but because they didn't do their job
because they won't lock criminals up she
is dead
is this compassionate we are told that
letting criminals off the hook for their
crimes and letting them out of prison
when they
do have to face consequences for their
crimes
is compassionate
we are told that america has an
over-incarceration problem specifically
with regard to to black men and so we've
got to let the criminals out of prison
is that compassionate to this woman
who's dead
is that compassionate to her family is
that compassionate to her co-workers
to any other ordinary american worker
who now is worried has to fear for their
lives if they're in a major city with a
big crime problem
is that even compassionate to the guy
the guy just killed this woman
he now i suspect will finally go to
prison
he's done a terrible thing that has
really destroyed his life is that
compassionate no i don't think so had he
been
thrown in the can for any of his other
crimes maybe he would have reformed but
now he
is not going to have that opportunity
before he killed someone the dems are
pushing this stuff
but the republicans are going along with
it
donald trump donald trump is one of the
most conservative republicans to come
along in my lifetime and donald trump
pushed the jailbreak bill
donald trump pushed the first step act
to let criminals out of prison it was
one of the
biggest disagreements i ever had with
the trump administration
why are you doing that this
issue of crime
is
one of the clearest areas of divergence
between the american people and both
major parties
the american people want criminals
locked up they don't want crime on their
streets
democrats do want crime on the streets
and republicans all too often go along
with it it's crime and immigration those
are the two big issues where the people
the vast majority of the people think
one thing and both major parties think
something completely different
the democrats want to let these
criminals out of prison with one
exception
they want to let everybody out of prison
there's one person they want to put into
prison do you know who that is
donald trump it would be donald trump
senate democrats are now reportedly
trying to lock up donald trump why i
don't know i can't possibly tell you
according to the hill
given the way to public evidence
democrat lawmakers want trump committed
believe that trump committed federal
crimes and want him locked up for it
but senate democrats also warn that
attorney general merrick garland needs
to proceed cautiously any prosecution
that fails to convict trump risks
becoming a disaster and could vindicate
trump just as the inconclusive report by
former special counsel robert
mullerstein these people are shameless
the inconclusive report mueller was this
close to getting trump for being a
secret kgb spy they were so close they
based the investigation on that
completely discredited dossier that was
funded by hillary clinton and it turned
out to be complete bunk but they were
close and it was inconclusive anyway
moving on moving on
trump was exonerated trump was
vindicated there so if
the democrats don't proceed cautiously
then donald trump might claim to be
exonerated even when he's not
for his crimes
well crimes
the best crime that they can name is
that donald trump led an insurrection a
threat to our democracy which doesn't
really mean democracy because even his
election was considered a threat to
democracy any time a republican wins an
election called a threat to democracy
and he encouraged the insurrection the
insurrection of course he didn't he said
be peaceful don't do anything bad when
people started to get a little rowdy at
the capitol he said go home stop it be
peaceful
and the democrats want to lock him up
for it i do not think this is a very
good idea not only because
i like donald trump and don't think he
committed any crimes
worthy of sending him to prison but also
because i don't think we should
prosecute our former presidents or
politicians or failed candidates in some
cases
i know we all chanted lock her up and it
was a lot of fun and we all loved that
moment in the debate where hillary
clinton said
i don't want to live in donald trump's
america and trump had that great singer
and he said yeah because you'd be in
jail and everyone just loved it it was
so boss and he was obviously a very
funny showman
but i don't think a lot of people really
want to live in a world where once you
lose power in america you just go to
prison
where we have our former presidents
wearing orange jumpsuits i don't want to
live in that
culture that is a symptom of a dying
culture that's a symptom of a political
order our democracy that's not
functioning
as it should
and if the democrats proceed on this
they should be very very careful because
if they proceed on this
then we're going to throw their their
next guy in jail it's going to be hard
to throw joe biden in jail
that would
seem to be a real a real abuse
we're going to throw kamala harrison joe
we're going to throw a pete butterjudge
i think that's the next one they want
we're going to throw pete buddha judge
in jail
we're going to do it it's going to
become just like impeachment now we just
always impeach the president
this is just what we do
people's claim that this started with
bill clinton
to some degree that might be fair
uh really i think it goes back much
further it goes back to the democrats
ousting richard nixon at least it goes
back to that
it's on it's unfortunate because senator
cruz who i was just speaking with last
night senator cruz pointed out that the
republicans if they retake the house as
it looks increasingly likely that they
will
they very well
might impeach joe biden why i don't
really think joe biden's committed an
impeachable offense
maybe maybe now i guess there's an
argument to be made but i don't think
that we should just impeach every
president
that's not what our framers and founders
intended but if the democrats are going
to do it we can't unilaterally disarm
same thing goes here
and this is much more significant than
mere impeachment they impeached donald
trump twice no one really remembered it
no one cared it didn't really matter
we're locking these people up if you
start this democrats
we're gonna have to play that game too
and right now if joe biden went to
prison i do not think there would be
many tears in america there would be
some tears of joy
but i don't think there would be many
tears because people think he's doing a
terrible job don't take my word for it
look at the polling
there's a new poll out that shows that
40
4-0 of voters approve of joe biden's job
performance that's according to politico
and morning consult that is a record low
for the survey
56 of respondents disapprove of joe
biden's job performance biden faces a 59
disapproval among independents the group
that he's got to sway over to his side
they they were the ones depending on
your views of the 2020 election
they they played an important role in
joe biden ending up in the white house
it's not just one poll i mean you've
heard these bad poll numbers again and
again and again real clear politics has
a polling average they look at all the
polls and they compile them together for
the first time joe biden's average
approval rating is below 41
he's now at just 40 for 0.9 percent
according to the to the rcp average
biden's average disapproval rating is
well over 50 it's
53.3
which means he's over 12 points
underwater
i think this is more about the media
than joe biden i don't want to let biden
off the hook he's doing a terrible job
he's probably the worst president in
american history
but i think it's more about the media
joe biden doesn't believe anything i
mentioned this yesterday with regard to
kamala harris it's certainly true of joe
biden too he doesn't believe anything he
wakes up in the morning he licks his
index finger he puts it up in the air
and he tries to figure out which way the
wind is blowing
when he thought it was helpful to his
career to style himself a moderate he
did when he felt that it was conducive
to his career to become a leftist he did
he just moves wherever the winds are
and the winds that were being fanned by
the establishment media by big tech by
the whole ruling class were moving in
the leftist direction so he ran as a
leftist candidate and made a lot of
leftist promises and now he can't get
anything done that he wants to do
and the media even beyond the ideology
of it all the media said if you elect
joe biden he's going to stop coronavirus
if you elect joe biden we're going to go
back to normal we're going to be rich
the economy is going to be great we're
going to have all of our rights which
everything's going to be
hunky-dory and then that didn't happen
and now people are upset
the left couldn't manage expectations
and now people are very upset
joe scarborough
who i actually ran into at a restaurant
last night in washington dc is a very
strange town you just run into all of
these people and they all live here and
they all know one another
and joe scarborough who's a former
republican congressman turned liberal
democrat type on msnbc he's giving
advice to the democrats he's saying
stop running as these radical leftists
you've got to run in a more moderate way
the democrats have 50 senators
the republicans have 50 senators one of
the great mysteries uh and i want lemire
to talk about this in a second one of
the great mysteries for historians are
going to look back and say how is it
that this guy ran against a dozen or so
progressives he was the only moderate he
ran as a moderate he won as a moderate
every single progressive got rejected
one uh like those debates were crazy
they were talking about re-implementing
busing they were so far left they wanted
to give health care to illegal
immigrants like it was so come across
the border we'll give you health care it
was so wildly out of the mainstream of
where about eighty percent of americans
are biden ran as a moderate biden won as
a moderate biden decided and his people
around him i guess decided that he was
going to govern
as a leftist it has failed miserably
joe scarborough is basically right here
but he doesn't understand why he's right
he doesn't understand why joe biden is
doing all of this he seems befuddled
that's why he's yelling
joe biden is a moderate even today joe
biden is a moderate he's a moderate in
his party joe biden is always a moderate
in his party
when his party is much more conservative
then he's a moderate
in that party when the party is
extremely radical and pushing socialism
and pushing transgenderism and pushing
radical racial theories and all these
things then he's a moderate in that
party too he's not the most extreme
leftist politician
it just so happens that the left has
moved the overton window the left has
moved their own party so far over that
to be a moderate there is to be
extremely leftist
by the standards just a few years ago
so the establishment liberals like joe
scarborough they realize gosh this isn't
working what are we going to how did
this happen
it happens because liberalism is not
stable
it just keeps moving
it just keeps moving toward
the left
it hates tradition it tears down statues
it says everything that came before us
was wrong and evil and unjust and we've
got to remake the world anew using only
our own unfettered reason
and so it just keeps moving and it can't
stop itself
now there is a reaction against that you
want to talk about radicalism up at
america's hat canada
canada has taken the covet lockdowns
very very seriously they're running in a
video right now it's gone viral around
the internet
of a woman interviewing children about
the unvaccinated and what the
unvaccinated should have happened to
them and the children say
they're cast them out of society
exact
[Laughter]
[Music]
what should happen to the unvaccinated
what should happen when you encounter
them the kid says we should call the
police
you don't have the vaccine
coerce them and bully them and push them
and push them and push them little by
little until they get vaccinated
insane
callous
and really ugly obviously what they're
doing to children is really ugly i think
parents are looking at that not the most
rock ribbed right wingers necessarily
but parents generally are looking at
that and saying look whatever political
agenda and ideology is doing this to the
two kids in this country indoctrinating
them in this crazy way
i'm out that's what you saw happen in
virginia with glenn younkin that's what
you're seeing in a lot of districts
around america it's a revolt of the same
normal people against the ruling class
which is why americans are shifting so
rapidly toward the republican party
which is why the democrats are bewailing
the grave threat to democracy i'm
michael nolan's the michael knowles show
we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
john bickley here daley wire
editor-in-chief
wake up every morning with our new show
morning wire
on today's episode a morning wire
exclusive poll on americans views on dr
fauci
tensions ramp up between russia and
ukraine
and the fda says to consider race before
administering covet treatments
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire